hey guys Ryan right here and though this
to be crazy alright y'all we're gonna be
checking out a video called how to order
McDonald's like a boss yeah yeah have
had many many people saying I should
check this out I [ __ ] love McDonald's
but I'm starting to dye it again so I
can't eat it but I [ __ ] love
McDonald's McDonald's is really good I
love McDonald's
oh god in their breakfast yeah ob person
Oh prankster errors I know that what's
up we're hoping for model pranksters
today I'm here with high res we're in
New York City we're gonna show you how
to order McDonald's like a boss hope you
guys enjoyed the video
got good luck you guys I get you Big Mac
rap about actually let me get to Big
Macs and two apple pies I get a five
gonna get a mix up but let me get a me
chicken pops up they shut it kick and I
want to make rig before me pitch let me
get a hash brown to visit lunch and
every dance I'm running sad and upset
and get some nuggets ooh I want a broad
cake in a plane to a damn I really had a
hard day
let me get a mid-calf a lot say and a
couple hundred lost shamrock shakes got
a red-hot see ranch that crap with a
star please let me get a burger with a
slice of cheese but no one your typical
saw on that please
I want to make flurry show windows point
Eminem while Oreos I want everything on
the dollar man you're going to Berg away
I love cameos could we get a snapback
for my bad habit and I'll check that
just also as I take everything back in
the black bag how there's another
flapjack
hope you guys enjoyed that video make
sure you subscribe to high-res the link
will be at the end of this video and on
top of the description you don't want to
miss him
that was really cool I was fantastic
that was actually like a really good rap
right Wow
you know I know it's a joke but damn it
that makes you want McDonald's the whole
time I couldn't tell if he was getting
it or not yeah I'm really really
focusing yeah hard are just like totally
over I thought he was getting it the
whole time I was like this guy really
jotting it down while everyone else is
just looking no that was really funny
man that is how to order McDonald's like
a boss that is the way to do it one time
I went to McDonald's this is a true
story one time I went to McDonald's they
got my order wrong and I was with my
brother and my brothers like you should
complain you should you should throw a
scene really and I was like okay so I
went up to them and I was like you guys
got my order wrong again every [ __ ]
time my [ __ ] consorts ain't [ __ ] a
lot yeah every [ __ ] time I [ __ ]
come here you guys [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
order they're like I'm sorry then they
gave me two apple pies and then I took
it too far
I took the joke too far then I was like
man [ __ ] this and I had the bag and I
went like just don't get out of there
but then all the food went flying out of
the bag so it didn't I didn't get a new
food oh yeah that is not how you order
McDonald's like a boss no but this is I
would love to go in and like do that rap
for someone like ah honestly I think you
could like for those of you who don't
know he can do the really fast part of
rap God so I feel like if you just sat
down and learned this you could totally
do it I would love to learn it at yeah
and another thing too is I really
respect this guy for not going through
the drive-thru like out everyone else
was he like literally went up to the
cashier had all the employees looking at
him customers right because most people
would just do the drive-thru I like how
he actually went up to the cashier very
Mills got levels well it was also really
smart cuz you can see more of what's
going on you can see more people behind
the counter whereas if you're in a
driver you only have a very small little
window yeah you can't eat reactions
fancy that yeah that was a great video
thanks guys if you're new the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out crazy sauce channel
elissa be crazy you follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where if
we get enough followers we can get
product placement for um [ __ ] keys
yes we would love key companies to
sponsor us little keys medium keys keys
are great keys keychains yo you know you
can lock lock up [ __ ] and you get keys
and also when you manipulate a Christian
girl into bed you put a [ __ ] key for
the chastity belt on there that's that's
what this heart is mm-hmm
we pan out stack and holdin underwear
and then BAM she loses her virginity to
you all because you had the right keys
I'm never gonna get legit product list